it is time to officially recognize
Jerusalem as the capital of Israel the
US has officially moved its embassy in
Israel from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem and in
doing so President Trump has reversed
decades of consensus about the city's
status while Israeli leaders celebrated
Palestinians denounced the move
deepening divides between two sides of a
conflict that seventy years old we're
hearing live fire rising death toll
quite a juxtaposition here are five
things to know about Jerusalem and why
it's so contentious both Israelis and
Palestinians consider Jerusalem their
capital Israel has controlled West
Jerusalem since 1949 during the six-day
war Israel captured East Jerusalem and
annexed that half of the city but the
international community considers East
Jerusalem occupied territory whose fate
needs to be part of a negotiated deal
between Israel and the Palestinians in
1980 after Israel passed a law declaring
a united Jerusalem their capital the
United Nations condemned the annexation
Palestinians want to divide the city and
make East Jerusalem the capital of a
future Palestinian state while Israelis
want a unified Jerusalem to be their
capital Jerusalem is central to the
peace process during peace process
negotiations for the Oslo Accords the
issue of Jerusalem was initially set
aside to avoid D railing the talks
[Applause]
any successful peace initiative in the
future would likely need to resolve the
conflicting claims to the land violence
is not new in the holy city control of
Jerusalem has been a trigger for
violence many times in the past the
contested area of East Jerusalem is home
to some of the holiest sites in the
world for Jews and Muslims it is the
site where Judaism's two sacred temples
once stood and the site where the
Prophet Mohammed ascended to heaven the
trouble is that the sites for Muslims
and Jews exist on the same land there's
a precarious power share in place
Israeli officials control who has access
to the complex but Muslims have
religious control inside Jews can enter
but aren't allowed to pray instead they
use the Western Wall the Second Intifada
began in 2000 when then opposition
leader Ariel Sharon visited the Temple
Mount to assert Israel's right to the
complex Palestinians protested and were
met with tear gas and rubber bullets the
violence lasted five years and killed
over 3,000 Palestinians and nearly 1000
Israelis with thousands more wounded the
US isn't the only country moving its
embassy in the early 70s sixteen
countries had embassies in Jerusalem
including the Netherlands and Colombia
but after the UN Security Council
condemned the annexation of East
Jerusalem in 1980 member states left
then Trump signaled a change in policy
in Guatemala and Paraguay also announced
they are moving their embassies to
Jerusalem and it's possible that more
countries will follow America's lead the
US has avoided the embassy move for
decades though Congress passed a law to
relocate the US Embassy to Jerusalem
more than 20 years ago the law includes
a loophole that allows the president to
delay the relocation for the sake of
national security
every sitting president Clinton Bush
Obama has used this power and signed the
waiver every six months president Trump
signed the waiver in June 2017 and again
in December 2017 but also signaled he
would begin the process of moving the
embassy from Tel Aviv
to Jerusalem and in May of 2018 he
carried out his pledge the embassy move
came at an already tense time tens of
thousands of Palestinians have spent the
past few weeks holding protests on the
border between Gaza and Israel that
weren't tied to the embassy move
dozens of Palestinians have been killed
even before the embassy opened while
President Trump was careful not to call
Jerusalem an undivided capital Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu said
just that at the u.s. embassy opening
and God bless Jerusalem the eternal
undivided capital of Israel but
opposition to Trump's declarations and
the embassy move has been growing and as
lines are drawn and the fight for
Jerusalem intensifies the future of
israeli-palestinian stability is once
again at risk
[Music]
you